you know the guy i'm a met who works for
us he was single for a long time met
this girl mary he proposed to his
girlfriend he's getting married i was
happy for the guy but then i was told in
the last staff meeting mimet uh
announced he's getting married on a day
we do the radio show i can i go what and
he invited a whole bunch of people from
the show to go and of course if they're
working for me they can go to my met's
wedding but
you know don't bother coming back
i mean what are you kidding me there's
weekends there's uh thursdays fridays
why would you get married on a day that
i'm doing a radio show one of the few
days that you're needed why would you do
that well
there's lots of different things with
like family and the day we wanted to do
it and the time the place was available
so there were lots of things out of my
control and i apologize that it's during
the week i feel terrible about it but uh
and i don't want anyone to feel pressure
if they don't want to come i just wanted
people to know that i wanted them
included if they wanted to to be there
man
how do these things get out of his
control you know he acts like he doesn't
have anything to do with it yeah he acts
like he's prince harry and like you know
like you gonna well you know the queen
insists that we uh you know i mean what
the [ __ ]
you're so right no one's insisting
anything i can't believe you're getting
married dude you were pretty much like
all that even the proposal is like
everything is so damn stressful there's
some trivia game that momet plays with
his fiancee moment somehow managed to
get the game to make the trivia question
his proposal asking this bonus question
is guest hqt mimit
hi mary here's the big question
will you marry me
yes no
or denmark
and here's a free eraser
uh-oh you better make up your mind mary
i know the people you invited are upset
because they're like first of all the
whole [ __ ] they're saying is momet had
to know that the staff can't miss work
and fly to his wedding evidently it's in
california so the invite comes as a
demand for money basically it's like
yeah just send me some cash everyone's
all pissed off
i understand i i invited more people
from here than my own family i've worked
here like eight years this place so why
would you get married without them well
it's not just me getting married it's
two people with two lives well you sit
down with your wife this is a pretty
important discussion and you go listen
let's do it on a weekend
you know i hear you i hear you it's just
weird
i know it didn't work out that way and
if people can't come again how does it
not work out that way though i don't
even understand like what do you mean
the two of you are planning it you act
like it was done to you i'm one of the
guys that's upset and i'm not i love
moments i met this isn't like a personal
thing but i got your invite in the mail
and i was excited uh uh for everything
and then i noticed it was the
destination wedding and right away my
wife is like well you're going to that
by yourself because i'm not getting on a
plane and all this stuff with covid and
i said yeah something to really think
about and i sat down at the computer to
put it on the calendar and it's like
it's a [ __ ] wednesday
what am i supposed to do like fly out
after the show on tuesday halfway across
the country
at three in the morning wherever this is
do my job and then go to a wedding on a
wednesday night and he doesn't want you
that's the show for the next day or for
the next one just send a gift just how
much how much money would you would you
want from jason for your wedding give me
the number 65 ahead 150 ahead
whatever you want to do i i understand
are you gonna have kids
uh i don't there's no plan right now
good he's got wacky ideas about how to
raise children that are outright
disturbing and he should never have
children well since he doesn't make any
of his own decisions he'd better check
to see if he's having children you got
to hear this i hope you're not serious
about this
would ensure his child would not grow up
to be an obnoxious brat by raising him
using fear and psychological torture
here's my met's idea of parenting what
do you think your parenting philosophy
would be
i would just you know make sure my child
is not an obnoxious brat and knows how
to behave in public how would you the
same way i was raised fear how do you do
that fear yes do you believe in spanking
a child if you psychologically torture
them early enough you can get in their
head where you don't have to raise a
hand to them how do you psychologically
torment them well you yell at them make
them scared of the world you know you
make them feel insecure about themselves
jesus you actually go against all the
experts the experts say make a child
feel safe and secure teach them how to
fly on their own well just i mean just
robin you were in the air force think
about our military how do we train
people in the military you break them
down until they're like nothing and then
you build them back up and that's why
we're the strongest fighting forces in
the world but you won't your children
won't have anything to break down you
will have broken them you forget the
build and back up part of it break them
then you build them i know what i'm
going to get you for a wedding gift
a waterboarding kit for the kids
thank you